i have 227 pending challenges
oh dear
yeah there is a less than 0.5 percent
chance of
i guess playing this player good luck to
lal
ruffle see playing a bird's opening
yeah the bird is a word
let's play the frogs gambit
let's just sack all the pawns
i was showing this other day so i'm down
two pawns
but uh i have a little bit more
development
thank you pascal john subbing for 10
months
in soccer hi eric how do you decide what
to play if you're in time
trouble
oh um
a lot of it is relying on intuition
where you don't want to think too much
in your decision-making process
you just want to kind of rely on
instinct
and though the way you build up in
intuition is through
just playing a lot getting a ton of
experience
i can't resist this looks too much fun
i'm sacking
so far i've sacked two pawns now i'm
sacking a bishop for coupons
so i'll be down a full bishop
but the goal is to justify it
there's a potential line where i
queenside castle with meat
i'm three moves away actually
i don't think it's gonna happen but it
would be cool if it happens
so white's only developed piece is a
king
all other pieces still in the back rank
i mean white's played probably
is why you played the best move so far
and white really hasn't blundered it's
just getting weird
and it's a situation where it's very
easy to
blunder as white
oh let's check
just sacking more pieces
because why not white has one legal move
oh no my bishop
wait i pre-moved knight c6 oh no
ah i'm sacking all the material this
game
what did i say this was a line i was
actually kind of thinking of
it worked out queen side castling with
meat on move 11.
oh that was so beautiful i was really
i was really beautiful
how many things did i sack also thanks
for the game
left will see i feel kind of cruel
but thanks for being part of the
masterpiece
so sack two pawns sacked a bishop
sacked a knight sacked another bishop
don't forget to subscribe to eric
rosenclips
oh yeah yeah thanks for the reminder
and if if you have prime you can
subscribe for free on twitch
so basically i sacked two pawns three
minor pieces
and castle queen side with mate
all in 11 moves
it's got to be like one of the most
aesthetic games i've
maybe ever had i don't think i've ever
castle queenside with mate this early
so that was nice if if you're watching
in the future
on youtube twitch chat says hi
um i know it's still
kind of asynchronous communication but
youtube is being very friendly the other
day
let me show some youtube comments too
yeah look so twitch chat says hi
but then youtube says hi back to twitch
it's just a nice kind of
back and forth